um
uh
okay
i think we're good yeah
um just so you know that even even with
the transferring
like perfectly i did notice
i think
all right man okay all right
uh
i'm
okay
right
okay
okay
um
is
and i'll i'll send that
okay thank you sir
okay okay
is
foreign
oh so
okay
yes
is
oh
right just not everybody you know
oh
hey
so
like
thank you
do you think
how are you doing
right
really that is news
okay
oh
oh
audio check one two one two
hey you guys have you back there hey
what's up man
why don't you check one two three one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
happy okay thanks
so you're like
um
yes
what's up
um
oh
yes
[Music]
uh
for you
um
is that the receiver
and i'll put
thank you very much
[Music]
it is
nice to see you nice to see you
that'll be your close-up for sure oh my
god
you know
should i bump it
what
oh
but they never
because
yes
foreign
i like that
not fair
um
we didn't go upstairs
this
all right let's do this
oh
that's a part
okay
it might inspire you
this is
okay
um
okay thank you sir two minute warning
hey yep
hey
she's
mm-hmm
uh
[Music]
thank you very much
nice to be with you all good evening
before providing today's update on the
china virus i want to address
the violence looting and rioting taking
place
in the democrat-controlled cities of new
york
portland chicago and seattle
the mayors and governors of these states
and cities have an absolute duty to use
all resources necessary to end the
violence
and all of the injury and death new york
city has an army of great police i know
them very well
and uh the law enforcement and the new
york's finest are as good as it gets
and they should be allowed to do their
job if they do their job if they're
allowed to do their job
the new york city problem will be solved
and be solved quickly
they do it well the mayor bill de blasio
should immediately hire back
all of the police who were fired
without justification they were fired
i guess that's part of defund the police
by the democrats they should hire new
york city's finest back you have some
incredible
policemen doing specific jobs that
nobody else can do
actually when it comes to terrorism and
other things
together the city of chicago and the
state of illinois have
25 000 police officers sheriffs and
guardsmen available to quell any
violence they can do it very quickly
very easily if allowed to do their jobs
again
if allowed to do their jobs our police
our law enforcement is incredible but
they have to be allowed to do their jobs
the democrats or the radical left
democrats or both because they're
becoming one of the same if you look at
election results
the democrats are being taken over by
the radical left the city of portland
and the
state of oregon have ten thousand fine
officers and guardsmen available
seattle washington and washington state
have ten 000 available so seattle city
of seattle
and washington state itself they have
great people they have to be allowed to
do their job i'm urging them to
deploy these resources to protect their
citizens and to stop the violence
and all of the things that we watch on
television going on although
a lot of the unfortunately fake news
don't like to put it on
because it shows that the democrats are
doing a very bad job of law enforcement
they have to put it on
you have to be honest with the people of
this country
but i'm offering all available federal
support requested to stop the violence
and arrest the criminals we have to be
asked by the governors or the mayors and
we'll be there very
rapidly it's ready willing and able
we're all ready willing and able to go
to these jurisdictions and take care of
them we'll do them very quickly
you saw what happened in minneapolis
they ripped the city apart
when the national guard went in
it ended immediately it was immediate
and lasted these acts of destruction are
not isolated incidents but demonstrate
the
pattern of violent left-wing extremism
that you get to see if you're watching
the right
news program under any rational
definition the arson attack
on the police precinct in portland
would be considered an act of left-wing
domestic terrorism
they really are anarchists these are
left-wing anarchists
they are anarchists and i'm directing
the department of justice to
stop these anarchists immediately to
stop them
and to work with the city and the state
to get the job done local authorities
have to investigate and prosecute all of
these crimes
immediately we'll work with you and the
local authorities know who
they are they know where they come from
they know a lot about them
they ought to get their act together and
get it done and we're ready to help
if you need that help you shouldn't need
that help actually you should be able to
do it yourselves and get it done very
well again you have excellent
police and law enforcement but you have
to let them do their job
what you're seeing in portland seattle
new york chicago is really the democrat
road map for america
they want every city in america to
resemble portland in a form
they want to pass federal legislation
gutting and hamstring in every police
department in america
they want to get rid of your second
amendment they want to end cash bail
close
prisons to fund police departments or at
least
largely defund you see that with new
york a billion dollars they took out of
their police department and crime has
gone through the roof
and a point far left prosecutors who
side with the criminals and target
law-abiding citizens
if the left gains power no city town or
suburb
in our country will be safe
on the vaccine front some very good news
today i met with the leaders of
operation warp speed
our historic undertaking to produce a
safe and effective vaccine in record
time
we heard an update from the top
scientists in the government
and the leaders of pharmaceutical
companies
which right now aren't uh too thrilled
with me they're taking
millions of dollars worth of ads because
i've created
a favorite nation status for drugs which
is going to reduce
drug prices by 40 50 60 and maybe even
70
in some cases numbers that have never
been heard ever thought of
so when you see those ads remember that
means your
drug prices are coming down when you see
ads attacking your president
it's very simple that means drug prices
are going to be falling very soon
this evening i'm pleased to announce
that we have reached an agreement with
modernity to manufacture and deliver 100
million doses of their coronavirus
vaccine candidate
the federal government will own these
vaccine
doses we're buying them recently we also
secured partnerships with johnson and
johnson
as well as sanofi and gsx to
support the large-scale manufacturing
of their vaccines doing very well in
those vaccines tremendous
promise in every single one of them and
we have many of them
and there are years ahead of schedule
this would have been if it were
in the previous administration or any of
the previous administrations where we
are now would have taken years
three vaccine candidates are now in
phase three trials already
the final stage of clinical trials this
is the final stage
we are investing in the development and
manufacture
of the top six vaccine candidates to
ensure rapid delivery
the military is ready to go they're
ready to deliver a vaccine
to americans as soon as one is fully
approved by the fda and we're moving
very close to that approval
we're on track to rapidly produce 100
million doses as soon as the vaccine is
approved and
up to 500 million shortly thereafter
so we'll have 600 million doses
operation warp speed is the largest and
most advanced
operation of its kind anywhere in the
world and anywhere in history
we've treated more than 86 000 americans
with convalescent plasma
a recent mayo clinic study found that
this treatment may produce
results which are incredible we look to
a
reduction and reduce mortality rate by
50 percent
and possibly even more than 50 percent
i urge americans who have recovered from
the virus to go to coronavirus.gov
and sign up and donate we would really
appreciate that because
it's been very successful unbelievably
successful
and we would love you to go and donate
as we continue to confront the global
pandemic the united states economy is
rebounding with strength like nobody
thought possible
you've seen the numbers you see what's
going on yesterday today
and tomorrow in my opinion we're very
poised for
a great third quarter and very poised
for some great stock market numbers
and 401k numbers and everything else
today the dow jones
passed 28 000 points for the first time
more than a 50
surge since just march so we've
increased by 50 percent more than
since just march it has gained
approximately 9500 points
that same period march and has recovered
nearly all of its value since the virus
struck our nation think of that
america's economy is incredible
and its economic recovery is outpacing
our peer nations
last quarter the european union's gdp
decline
was nearly 40 percent worse than the
united states so it's 40
worse than the united states we've built
such a strong base
that we're able to do things and sustain
better than
anybody in the world by far france's gdp
decline was nearly 80 percent worse than
ours in spain
experiencing economic contraction twice
as severe as the united states
nationwide we continue to see
improvements in our
fight against the pandemic very
substantial improvements
since last week 87
of the counties in the united states
report declining cases
think of that 87 percent of the counties
in
the united states they reported
declining cases
mortality has declined by 7 and
hospitalizations are declining rapidly
states that were primary hot spots such
as florida texas and arizona
have reduced cases by nearly 25
but all americans must remain vigilant
practice good hygiene
socially distance wear a mask
whenever possible whenever you
are getting too close to people wear a
mask and
protect the elderly always protect the
elderly
since the end of july the seven-day
average for cases
in the united states has fallen by
nearly 20
but the virus continues to increase in
nations across the globe last week
france and germany both recorded their
highest daily number
of new cases in three months
not that i want to bring that up but
might as well
explain it to the media the seven-day
case average for germany has increased
by 62 percent since
last week unfortunately and that is
truly unfortunate
it's increased 82 percent in france
113 in spain and 30 percent in the
united kingdom
those are big increases cases
are also rapidly increasing in the
netherlands sweden belgium
switzerland slovakia estonia and other
european countries
and in our country they're going down
we will be seeing that even more rapidly
as time goes by
short time even though america has the
largest
at-risk population including 1.5 million
residents of nursing homes
about five times that of other european
countries europe has experienced a
nearly 40 percent higher
excess mortality rate
than the united states we also have
fewer deaths per capita
excluding the disastrous deaths from the
new york tri-state area which had a very
very hard time
and did better than our peer nations of
western europe
thanks to our excellent and highly
advanced medical care and skill
something that the news doesn't tell you
they don't tell you that they don't like
to tell you that
the united states has now conducted more
than
66 million tests far more than any other
nation in the world
india which has a population of 1.5
billion people
has done 24 million so we're at 66
million
and think of it india's at 24 million
and india's second the entire region
of latin america comprising 33 countries
has conducted 25 million tests yet latin
america has more confirmed cases by far
than the united states
as we safely restore our great economy
and reopen our schools and hopefully
we can watch colleges play football we
want to get football in colleges
these are young strong people they won't
have a big problem
with the china virus so we want to see
college football start
and hopefully a lot of
great people are going to be out there
they're going to be out there playing
football and
they'll be able to fight it off and
hopefully it won't bother them one bit
most of them will never get it
statistically
but we know we'll see more cases at some
point and
uh we will eventually develop sufficient
immunity
in addition to everything else that
we're doing so college football get out
there and play football people want to
see it and stand for your american flag
stand for your national anthem because
people are not happy when
that doesn't happen you look at the nba
and what's happening with the nba and
their poor ratings i don't know
can't imagine why but they didn't stand
they didn't show respect to
our flag they didn't show respect to our
ranch
or our national anthem and uh
maybe that's having an impact but just
uh not good the nfl had its problems two
years ago when that happened
they went way down in their ratings and
their fans
and they struggled back and now all of a
sudden they're putting themselves in the
same position so stand for your flag and
stand for the national anthem
and i think you're going to do
fantastically well
because a lot of people aren't going to
watch if you don't i'm one of them
that's why our strategy and attention
are focused on preventing the cases that
are
most likely to require
discussing the opening of schools
hospitalization or produce any death
we have to maintain vigilance over
our elderly population we've learned
that
i think more than any single event scott
we have to be very vigilant
all over but we have to really protect
our elderly population and especially
our elderly population that has
problems with heart
lung any form of
of sickness diabetes in particular
and we are at the same time in very good
shape with respect to hospital
room and hospital overcrowding we're in
great shape
on the nursing home front protecting our
nursing home residents is a critical
focus of our
strategy hhs recently announced that
they will
use the provider relief fund to deliver
an additional five billion dollars to
further protect nursing homes
and long-term care facilities as they
continue to combat the china virus
we have delivered over 1 800 rapid
point-of-care testing devices to nursing
homes
and we are in the process of delivering
these vice devices to all
15 000 medicare and medicaid certified
nursing homes
by the end of september so they're going
to have very very rapid tests
they won't have to wait around two or
three days or four days and
that number has come down very
substantially
compared to what it was when you send it
to the labs you get very accurate tests
but it takes a period of time to send it
to check it and then to send it back but
we are now
at a position where we're sending very
very
rapid test five minutes to 15 minutes
we will care for america's seniors as we
develop the vaccine
and therapeutics and therapeutics are
coming along
very very well we think we have some
great answers on therapeutics and you'll
be hearing that
about them in the very near future i'm
very much into
the world of therapeutics where you go
into the hospital
and you give a shot or you do what you
have to do
with it perhaps transfusion it's
combinations of
what you can do and people get better i
like that very much i like that uh
very very much and that could even
proceed
uh in a successful uh
in getting it that will i think probably
even precede vaccines
but therapeutically we're doing very
very well a lot of people are going to
be very happy when they see some of the
numbers that were that i'm seeing and
some of the results
so tremendous things are happening on
the vaccine front at the therapeutic
front
and uh our country should be very proud
of itself we're going to get it
delivered very rapidly as soon as it
comes out
okay uh questions please
thank you mr president 20 million people
are
due to be evicted from their homes next
month and
are you do you fear that this could be
your herbert hoover move moment
if you do not reach a deal with congress
to set up a new cares act
we are not allowing that to happen we're
stopping evictions
we are stopping evictions we're not
going to let that happen and also we're
not going to evict people we're not
going to let people
the democrats maybe they don't care but
i care
and we signed an executive offer you
know uh
executive order you know that right
and uh we are not letting people be
evicted
thank you thank you president trump uh
if i could have two questions
i'd like to ask you one about senator
harris's record
and then a different one about visa
abuse sure um so
regarding senator harris's record you
had a pretty
quick response to that you had an ad out
that said that she was a phony
and i wanted to drill down she was uh
and i wanted to ask about a specific
example that a lot of people thought was
a phony moment
as san francisco d.a she oversaw
according to the mercury news
1900 marijuana convictions but she was
asked in an interview last year if she
had smoked marijuana
and she appeared to joke and according
to some people lie and say that she was
listening to snoop dogg and toothpalk
well their music hadn't come out at the
time while she said she was smoking pot
listening to it
um why would she lie about that do you
see that as more evidence that is
surpassed on marijuana a liability
well she lied i mean she said things
that were untrue
she is uh a person that's
told many many stories that weren't true
she's very big into raising taxes she
wants to
slash funds for our military at a level
that nobody's
can even believe she uh
is against fracking fracking is she's
against
petroleum products i mean how do you do
that and go into pennsylvania or
ohio or oklahoma or the great state of
texas she's against
fracking fracking's a big deal
she's in favor of socialized medicine
where you're going to lose your doctors
you're going to
lose your plan she wants to take your
health care
plans away from 180
million americans 180 million americans
that are very happy with their
health insurance and she wants to take
that away
so she was my number one pick i mean she
was i as they would say
because hopefully you'll start college
but well she was my number one
draft pick and we'll see how she works
out
she did very very poorly in the uh
primaries as you know she was expected
to do well
and she was she ended up at
right around two percent and spent a lot
of money
she had a lot of things happening and so
i was a little surprised that he picked
her
i've been watching her for a long time
and i was a little surprised she was
extraordinarily nasty to
uh kavanaugh judge cavanaugh then now
justice kavanaugh she was nasty to a
level that was
just uh a horrible thing the way she was
the way she treated
now justice kavanaugh and i won't forget
that soon
so she did very poorly in the primaries
and now she's chosen so let's see how
that all works is the marijuana
legalization vote for you rather than
her because she convicted so many people
in the past
uh i can't tell you what she's voting
for i don't think she knows what i think
joe knows even less than she does but i
was only surprised at the pick a lot of
people were saying that might be the
pick
i was more surprised than anything else
because she did so poorly many people
did much better than her in the primary
she did very poorly in the primaries
and that's like a poll you know that's
like a poll i'd also ask you about vice
abuse
president trump um yes about fice abuse
um so now it's widely accepted among
republicans
there was spice abuse tremendous uh the
justice department ig
has found that with the current page
board application but uh we were
actually
warned in 2013 that the surveillance
court was allegedly a rover stand
it was approving surveillance and i was
wondering uh i don't think as president
you've commented on edward snowden but
do you think you should be allowed to
return
without going to prison so as far as
fiser abuse is concerned there was
tremendous visor abuse it's amazing that
it's taken this long and everyone knows
that it's been
proven very substantially not only fisa
abuse
changing documents and putting documents
in front of
the fisa court in courts that are
disgraceful that they could have done it
and the fact is we caught
joe biden president obama the whole
group
you can look at brennan and comey and
clapper
the whole group we caught him spying on
our campaign
this was an illegal act like no other
illegal act this was
treason this was at the highest level of
treason
and obama and biden got caught
spying on my campaign using
intelligence agencies of the united
states government to do it
both before and after the election
so before the election then after i won
they continued
it's total illegal activity and now we
just have to see what's happening but as
far as
kamala is concerned she's a big tax
raiser she's a big
slasher of funds for our military and
she's
got a lot of difficult things that she's
going to
have to explain plus she was very very
nasty
to one of the reasons that surprised me
she was very she was probably nastier
than
even pocahontas to joe biden she was
very disrespectful to joe biden
and it's hard to pick somebody that's
that disrespectful when
she said things during the debates
during the
democrat primary debates that were
horrible about
sleepy joe and i would think that he
wouldn't have picked oan please
thank you mr president yesterday seattle
city council
voted to uh cut funding for their police
department and the chief the police
chief there
carmen best the first black woman to
serve in that capacity she resigned
hours later
what does this say about our country
what does this say about the defund
police movement
well i think that seattle in
spite of all that they've been through
with the embarrassment of having a
radical left group antifa and others
take over a big portion of
the city of seattle we're talking about
a big city a major city
that they allowed that to happen is
incredible that it took so long to fix
is incredible the only reason they went
in is because they knew
we were going in the following day and
so they
preceded us they didn't want that to
happen they didn't want to be
embarrassed
and the people just gave up they weren't
they were exhausted from
having taken over a city for so long uh
the police commissioner seems like a
very good woman
they were going to slash her salary by
40 or 50 percent
and they cut a tremendous amount off the
police department
really where people are saying it's not
sustainable as a good police department
and again those police are good also
but they're not allowed to do their job
so i think it's a shame
i hate to see her go because she did in
her own way a very good job but
she wasn't effective in convincing
the mayor and the city council to give
the funds that were needed
or just leave the funds the way they are
they've done a big
a big defund a big part of it
and it'll probably get worse before
people realize this is a tragic era
before people start dying
and getting hurt very badly so i think
seattle's made a
tragic mistake i think portland uh
has no clue as to what they're doing
they have no clue
and hopefully they'll be asking for help
because we can solve their problem
very very quickly yeah go ahead thank
you sir mr president
uh two quick questions one on uh senator
harris
very simply is she going to help but uh
former vice president biden's chances in
november or is he record
well i like vice president mike pence
much better he is solid as a rock
he's been a fantastic vice president
he's done
everything you can do he's respected by
every religious group
whether it's evangelical whether it's
any other group
they respect mike pence he's been a
great vice president
and i will take him over
kamala and the horrible way she again
treated
justice cavanaugh that was a horrible
event i thought it was terrible for her
i thought it was terrible for our nation
i thought she was
the meanest
the the most horrible most disrespectful
of anybody in the
u.s senate she's also known
from what i understand as being just
about the most liberal
person in the u.s senate and i would
have thought that biden would have tried
to
stay away from that a little bit because
with what they're doing with open
borders and
sanctuary cities where they're trying to
protect sanctuary cities which is also
protecting large number of criminals
with all of the things that they're
doing second amendment
they want to take away your second
amendment or modify it to a point
where it's essentially no longer the
second amendment i would have thought he
would have gone a different way
thank you very much
[Music]
mr president russia developed a vaccine
today mr president why did you donate to
kamala harrison
six thousand dollars
uh
it could be worse
god
he's trending
okay
everybody
this is just the beginning yeah
it's going to be bloody a bloody road
uh
you